SIERRA: Japan. A place known for its exceptionally
good food, its pop culture, and its sprawling,
fast-paced cities. When it comes to geopolitics
though, it doesn t get talked about as much
as neighbors like Russia and China. But out
of the spotlight, and behind the curtain,
Japan is a powerful global player, and one
of the United States most important allies.
The partnership has been cemented over decades,
grounded in shared goals, and shared values.
But Japan also has a problem: it s running
out of people. Its population is growing older,
and not enough babies are being born. If the
trend continues, it could weaken the country
s role on the world stage, and this could
have serious implications for the U.S., and
the future of Asia. I m Gabrielle Sierra,
and this is Why It Matters, today, a demographic
problem in Japan.
SIERRA: So the world's attention is going
to be turning to Japan soon because the Olympic
Games are going to be beginning. Is there
a simple way to describe what life is like
there?
RICH: It's sort of the lifestyle superpower
of the world. It's a very easy place to live,
at least on the surface.
SIERRA: This is Motoko Rich. She s the Tokyo
bureau chief for the New York Times.
RICH: And then I think it's when you dig just
a little bit below, you see that there are
a lot of problems, some of them looming in
the future and some of them very much there
today, and that makes it a place of somewhat
cognitive dissonance, maybe like all societies,
but I think Japan, because it looks so beautiful
and so efficient and so fun, especially in
a place like Tokyo or Osaka and Kyoto on the
surface, I think people don't realize what
might be lurking beneath.
SIERRA: Right. So let's talk about one of
those issues. Can you tell me a little bit
about Japan's demographic problems?
RICH: Well, the predominant issue is that
it is rapidly aging. It's currently considered
the oldest country in the world in terms of
the proportion of the population that's already
over 65. It's approaching about 30%, and it
will be more than that in about 10 years.
And the population has also been declining
for the last decade. So there are a lot of
old people and fewer and fewer young people.
SIERRA: It's just actually kind of hard for
me to imagine life in a country where everyone
is so old. I was kind of hoping that you could
help me imagine it. So let's say I'm a young
woman in Japan, maybe in the countryside or
maybe in a city, can you take me sort of on
a walk? Like what do I see? Do I feel this
happening around me?
RICH: Well, if you're a young woman in the
countryside, you're alone.
SIERRA: Wow.
RICH: I mean very recently I reported about
a young woman who she and her sister were
literally the last people to be born in their
town. In their late 20s, they're the youngest
people in their town. And she left her town
to study to become a nurse about two hours
away, but she's planning to go back and she's
going to specialize in geriatrics because
what else is there to do? She can't be a pediatric
nurse or a neonatal nurse.
SIERRA: Right.
RICH: If she were to walk to the bank, there
will be a rack with three different sets of
prescription reading glasses.
SIERRA: Oh my gosh.
RICH: Because the assumption is that somebody
might walk in, forget their glasses, and need
the reading glasses to look at the deposit
slip. If you go into the city office and there
are seats at the counter, there will be little
slots to put your cane. And then, like I said,
walking around town, everybody will be old.
With fewer babies being born and a rapidly
aging population, Japan is facing an unprecedented
demographic crisis with vast social, economic,
and political repercussions. Couples are waiting
longer to get married, are working more and
having fewer children, and there's a huge
cultural difference.
SHAW: Within around 20 years it's going to
be Losing 1 million people a year; the size
of a city.
SIERRA: This slow down may come as a surprise
if you associate Japan with bustling cities
and cutting-edge youth culture. But it s real.
Japan s 2020 census recorded a population
decline of 800,000 people, a year later the
percentage of its population under age 14
had fallen to its lowest level ever - just
11 percent. It s a big change. For much of
the 20th century, Japan was a story of booming
growth. By the 1980s, it had become the world
s second-strongest economy, and there were
widespread fears that it might even displace
the United States. That didn t happen, but
the country remains a pillar of the global
economy and a considerable force in international
diplomacy. But all of this is threatened by
their declining population.
SIERRA: So what kind of obstacles is this
issue creating, then, for Japan? What are
people worried about at the national level?
SMITH: So first and foremost, obviously, is
that the government will have to spend more
to take care of the elderly in Japan, be that
in health care costs, or be it in pensions.
SIERRA: This is Sheila Smith, Senior Fellow
for Asia Pacific studies at the Council on
Foreign Relations, and a widely followed expert
on Japan.
SMITH: The second is and it's related also
to the government, its revenue and that is
that the working population, as it gets smaller
right as more people retire and then the population
doesn't grow the share of the people who are
working age diminishes and that means less
revenue, less taxes, less income taxes specifically.
So there'll be fewer Japanese taking care
of a larger proportion of the population.
So that ratio between working and retiree
will shift considerably. But there are larger
social questions and Japan for the last decade
or more has been grappling with some of this.
Traditionally, the Japanese lived with their
nuclear family, so often you'd have grandma
and grandpa living in the house with you.
That has changed as Japan became more urbanized
as attitudes towards households and families
changed. You've now got a lot of elderly people
living alone. And so you've had a pretty widespread
shift in the norms regarding elderly care.
So now you have a lot more nursing facilities,
you've got public private partnerships on
how to deal with that, especially as I noted
in rural sectors of Japan, this elderly care
question doesn't just affect, you know, do
we build a home? And how do we get caregivers
to take care of elderly people, but also just
simply the hollowing out of Japan's smaller
cities and towns.
SIERRA: Eldercare is expensive, and once they
retire, older people are no longer contributing
directly to the economy through labor. Countries
need young and working age people to pay taxes
that keep the country running, and to start
the businesses that fuel growth. If the percentage
of elderly keeps rising, and the percentage
of young people keeps falling, this system
breaks down, tax revenue decreases, and labor
shortages set in. One UN study found that
Japan would have to raise the retirement age
to 77 in order to maintain its current worker-to-retiree
ratio.
RICH: Japan is kind of a place where the world
can look to see what the future looks like,
right? We now know that the population is
declining in the United States. China's going
to be facing this. South Korea is already
facing this. So there are a lot of lessons
that could be learned by looking at Japan.
A little bit of history. We go back to after
the war when Japan was occupied by the United
States until early 1950s, and then after that,
it kind of took off economically. And the
way they accomplished that, by and large,
was creating this work culture where everyone
sort of were pulling together as part of what
they call Japan Inc to kind of rebuild the
country and make it an economic superpower.
And it was largely men, and the men would
devote their entire lives to the company,
not just in terms of their entire careers,
but literally every day of their lives, that
they were there long, long hours. They often
worked weekends. And the structure that enabled
that was having a very strong traditional
nuclear family with women at home taking care
of the children. Then the bust came when the
kind of real estate bubble in Japan collapsed
in the very early '90s, and then women were
starting to go back to work partly because
of necessity. If they were part of a nuclear
family, the family needed more income, the
women were entering the workforce. Then there
was this sense, a little bit of, trying to
empower women and actually allow women and
encourage women to have their own careers.
And then at the same time, Japan was not kind
of changing those standards of what was expected
of women in the home. So if they wanted to
have those careers but also marry and have
children, they were expected to do so much
at home, that many women were looking at that
and saying, "We can't do that. We can't do
both." I mean, these are similar themes that
are now just starting to play out in the United
States, but Japan has been kind of ahead of
the curve, if you will, on that trend since
the '90s.
SIERRA: Many women are choosing not to marry,
and to delay or avoid childbirth altogether.
As a result, the youthful side of Japan s
population scale grows lighter and lighter.
Meanwhile, the elderly side grows heavier.
And that s because Japanese people tend to
live for a very long time. The average life
expectancy in Japan is 84 and climbing, the
highest of any nation on earth.
SMITH: So every year in Japan, when you're
watching TV, you get to see, you know, the
elderly ladies that are 104, 108, or 106,
you know, so their diet has allowed them to
have a healthy, older age. But that means
that the percentage of the population that's
elderly is larger because of that extended
life expectancy.
RICH: Longevity is of a feature of Japan.
People live really long lives, they're very
healthy, and you can just sort of see that
when you walk around. I mean, we use the word
genki, which means very healthy, and it's
sort of astonishing I think, certainly compared
to the West, where you just see people hiking
and walking, and even if they have canes,
even old women who are stooped over and practically
horizontal with the ground are still doing
their own shopping. It just sort of extraordinary
how people continue to be active at such old
ages in Japan.
SIERRA: Can you just paint a picture of what
Japan might face if its demographic decline
continues? You know, what are the fears?
SMITH: So I think the fears of an aging society
are obviously that Japan will lose its economic
vitality. And therefore it won't be able to
compete internationally in the way it has
so demonstrably in the post war era. But there's
also the Japanese fear, of course, that their
aging society may compromise your ability
to manage the geostrategic changes that are
taking place in the region. China is on the
rise. It's a bigger, more populous, more economically
vibrant country, Japan is going to have to
maintain its own economic and political vibrancy
if it is to live in the world, which has a
stronger China. Finally, I think it's important
that Japan doesn't turn inwards, that younger
Japanese don't say that the problems of the
world are too much for them. Japan has been
such a partner of the United States and many
other countries in support of the world that
we've created in the post war period. It's
been a vibrant advocate of liberal values,
of an open trading system of peace and security.
And so I think there is a slight danger that
Japan's younger population will turn inwards
and Japan will no longer be the strong partner
of ours, and of Europeans and of many others
in Asia, that you'll see a quiet isolated
Japan and that would be a loss for all of
us.
SIERRA: Japan s demographic decline is first
and foremost a problem for Japan itself. But
it could also be a problem for its many allies,
including the U.S. More on that, and a look
at potential solutions, after the break.
SIERRA: Hey Podcast Listeners! I m here to
tell you about another podcast I think you
ll enjoy: The Last Archive from Harvard historian
and New Yorker writer Jill Lepore. For this
season, Lepore is investigating purveyors
of doubt hoaxers, fraudsters, pseudoscientists
and how the peddling of doubt evolved over
the 20th century, leading all the way to the
Capitol Insurrection on January 6, 2021. This
show is unlike anything you ve heard before:
history animated by long lost archival tapes
and documents, intrepid reporting, and radio
drama reenactments. The Last Archive unfurls
like a classic 1930s gumshoe mystery but takes
on the big issues of today. How do we know
what we know, and why does it seem like lately
as if we don t know anything at all. Listen
to The Last Archive wherever you get your
podcasts. From Pushkin Industries.
Joe BIDEN: Prime Minister Suga and I affirmed
our ironclad support for U.S.-Japanese alliance,
and for our shared security. We are committed
to working together to take on the challenges
from China and on issues like the East China
Sea and the South China Sea. Our relationship
is in full bloom because the Japanese and
American people understand more and more that
our two nations and other like-minded liberal
democracies must work together.
SIERRA: If you went back in time 75 years,
a lot of Americans would be surprised to hear
that the U.S. and Japan are now so close.
After all, the two countries were fierce adversaries
in World War II. But in the wake of that conflict,
they forged a partnership that has grown and
thrived through the decades. The alliance
was initially designed to address Cold War-era
concerns in Asia. But that focus has changed.
SIERRA: Can you sort of walk me through the
most important elements of the US Japan alliance
as it stands now?
COOPER: The US-Japan alliance is very focused
right now, on the China challenge.
SIERRA: This is Zack Cooper, research fellow
at the American Enterprise Institute and Co-Director
of the Alliance for Securing Democracy at
the German Marshall Fund of the United States.
COOPER: It's arguably the most important thing
for American leaders today, especially on
foreign policy, it has been the most important
thing to Japan for years. And so in a lot
of ways, the Alliance is actually getting
stronger, because the challenges that we're
facing are growing more severe. China is very
close to Japan, right? They share some disputed
territory and maritime areas. It is the world's
second largest military and growing very rapidly.
It is surging that military often into areas
that are disputed with Japan, and it often
exhibits some public anger at Japan. And so
I think from a Japanese view, the perceived
threat level from China is quite high at the
moment. And obviously, the same is true of
the United States, especially over the last
two or three years.
SMITH: They have a sovereignty dispute. China
disputes Japan's administrative control over
a small set of uninhabited islands in the
East China Sea. The Hong Kong security law,
and the quelching of democratic practice in
Hong Kong has really worried the Japanese
as well. And then of course, there's the military
activities that the Chinese have been conducting
recently in and around Taiwan, which verge
on two pieces of that puzzle. One is the question
about whether or not China would actually
use force against a democratic nation. And
the second is, this is perilously close to
Japanese territory. So it spills over into
Japanese thinking about what the Chinese might
do, or whether a conflict over Taiwan might
actually spill over to involve Japan directly.
SIERRA: And China isn t the only worry. Japan
is also a neighbor of North Korea, and plays
an essential role in U.S. military planning
for a crisis on the Korean peninsula. Plans
like these are only possible because Japan
hosts several U.S. military bases on its territory.
COOPER: The first thing to be aware of is
that most of these bases are absolutely critical
to the US military's ability to carry out
its operations in East Asia. So we are more
dependent on Japan than any other location,
arguably, in the world. There are about 50,000
American forces in Japan, and many of them
are accompanied. So there's something like
100,000 American service members and families.
RICH: Part of the reason that the United States
has its largest contingent of military personnel
outside of the United States stationed in
Japan is precisely because they recognize
that that is a strategic location to protect
the whole region. It's not just about protecting
Japan. And I went down to Okinawa one time
and was meeting with the general who's in
charge of the Okinawa operations where there
are 25,000 US Marines based. And he pulled
down this huge wall map and just showed me,
"Look, Okinawa, Southern end of Japan. It's
so close to Taiwan, so close to China, it's
so strategic in the region." That is why the
United States is there. If they pulled back
and everything was based in California, it
would take so much longer to get to the region
in the case of the necessity to bring an aircraft
carrier. They have an aircraft carrier base
in Yokosuka, Japan. So it's right here if
God forbid there was something that they needed
to do, they're here. And that's not just for
the protection of Japan, that's for the protection
of the whole region. And in that sense, it
is also for the production of the United States.
SIERRA: Nobody wants war, or conflict. But
if conflict does break out in the Pacific,
the U.S. is deeply dependent on Japan to be
able to face the threat. And Japan, in turn,
depends on our backing. This two way street
isn t limited to military concerns. The Japanese
and American economies have been similarly
intertwined for a long time.
COOPER: So many people don't remember this.
But Japan is the world's third largest economy
and by quite a bit. So when we talk about
Japan, it still has a remarkably dynamic economy.
And it is globally integrated right into supply
chains and everything from microchips to automobiles.
And so Japan in a lot of ways, is a real engine
for global growth. And so sometimes I think
it's easy to forget that if you're buying
an automobile in the United States, there's
a pretty good chance that either the car you're
buying was designed in Japan, or that a lot
of its components were designed or made there.
And that's, that's going to continue, right.
And so I think these deep economic ties are
part of why the two countries are so closely
interlinked.
SMITH: Japan hovers at the number one or number
two position in terms of foreign direct investment
in the United States. Japan creates pretty
much around a million jobs, American jobs
every year through that foreign direct investment,
in addition to providing capital and obviously
goods that we Americans like to buy that are
produced here in the United States. So it's
a very vibrant relationship, both on the economic
side and the strategic side as well.
SIERRA: And there s another element at play,
too. The U.S.-Japan alliance is built in part
on shared democratic values, and shared diplomatic
goals.
COOPER: Japan is a democracy, it shares a
lot of the same values as the United States.
And so in each of these four areas, geo strategy,
economics, technology and governance, Japan
is a key player. And in fact, Japan might
be the only country in the world that shares
interests along all four of those areas. I
think what's not talked about enough, though,
is the fact that Japan is very active outside
of Northeast Asia. And it is seen incredibly
positively, in particular, in Southeast Asia.
So these are the large and rapidly growing
countries like Indonesia and Vietnam, that
are vital, not just right now, but to the
economy and the security situation in Asia,
say 10 or 20 years from now, in those countries,
Japan has by far the highest levels of trust
of any nation, far higher than the United
States, far higher than China, or even Europe.
Because Japan has been there and been present
and active and helping those economies grow.
So our interests are very much aligned. We
want Southeast Asian countries to be succeeding,
we want them to be democratic, protecting
human rights. And Japan has very similar interests
there. So I would say across the region, we
see very, very similar parallel efforts from
both Washington and Tokyo. And there are a
lot of times when actually, Tokyo has more
leverage to be helpful in Asia than Washington
does, because it's built up so much goodwill
over the years.
SIERRA: So it's kind of like we have a good
friend in Asia, who has many good friends
in Asia.
COOPER: That's right.
SIERRA: Japan needs a strong friend in the
U.S., and we need a strong Japan in turn.
And that s where Japan s demographic problem
becomes a global problem. If Japan continues
to shrink, it could begin to lose its regional
influence. It s voice could grow quieter.
And this in turn could reduce the power of
the alliance. That said, Japan has explored
a number of potential solutions to the problem.
SIERRA: Yeah. So we know that the Japanese
government is worried about all of this for
a number of reasons. So what type of solutions
are they attempting?
RICH: So one of the big solutions that they
started doing under the Shinzo Abe administration,
he had this, in consultation with a very high-powered
banker at Goldman Sachs, she had looked at
the sort of data and said, look, you have
got this very amazing untapped resource of
highly educated women who are not working
to their full potential. Why don't you empower
women to not just take, kind of part-time
or contract jobs, or menial labor, but really
put them in the economy in a very strong and
powerful way? And so he seized on this idea
and dubbed it womenomics. And the idea was
that if we empower women and support them
in the workplace, we'll now have 50% more
of the workforce that had not been fully exploited,
for lack of a better word, and in some cases
that's the truth, that that will help embolden
the economy. So the main initiative was to
open more daycare centers, add more slots,
get more kids into daycare, but because of
the previously mentioned, I mean, it's a demographic
problem, right? To open more daycare slots,
you need more daycare teachers. And if you
don't have enough young people to fulfill
those jobs at the same time that there are
other women who want other jobs, but need
to send their kids to daycare, it's really
hard to do that. So it's taken them a really
long time. The new Prime Minister Yoshihide
Suga has talked about subsidizing fertility
treatments because a lot of couples have trouble
getting pregnant because they're waiting until
later to try to get pregnant, and so it's
sort of the same issues that are faced in
the West, but that again seems a little bit
like a band-aid. They're not really addressing
the fundamental core issue, which is that
because of the way the workplace culture is,
that it demands that people work these 16
hour days and on weekends and be available
at all times, that's really not conducive
to family life. And if the women have to do
everything at home, that is not conducive
to women really advancing in the workplace.
So it's sort of this Catch-22 that women just
can't get out of this cycle that they're stuck
in, even if they want to. So it's very, very
difficult for women.
SIERRA:
And you certainly can't go to women and be
like, "Have babies,"
RICH: No, which is what they have done. There
are conservative politicians who from time
to time say it's a woman's duty to go out
and have at least three children and stay
home and care for them. That is not an effective
policy. So I think a lot of the things that
they're trying to do are sort of these little
band-aids on the edges and they're not really
addressing the fundamental core issues.
SIERRA: Japan s efforts to increase fertility
haven t worked so far, but that doesn t mean
that such policies can t ever work. Take Sweden,
which decades ago faced its own demographic
decline. Since then, the country s generous
social security systems have been credited
with encouraging gender equality and giving
women the freedom to both work and care for
their children. Key features include accessible
daycare services and lenient leave programs
for both mothers and fathers. Over time the
strategy helped boost the country s fertility
rate, and could be a potential model for other
countries. But increasing the fertility rate
is not the only option for solving a demographic
problem.
RICH: So, The other big, big, big elephant
in the room is immigration. That is how population
growth has been maintained in a lot of big,
large aging countries.
COOPER: You know, Japan has a remarkably advanced
society. Where it's actually going to struggle
to find people to do critical roles. So some
of this is things like child care and elder
care, where in fact, you know, people like
home health aides are going to be really important.
And there just may not be enough of a population
in Japan to serve those roles. So there are
a very large number of experts in this area
from the Philippines who are well trained
and very capable. And bringing in more of
those types of immigrants is a potential solution
for Japan to help solve some of its challenges.
So I think, increasingly, it's going to be
vital for Japan to expand its labor market
look, not just internally for ways to convince
women to have more children, but also externally
to find ways to bring new people into Japanese
society. This isn't easy. It's socially hard.
It's politically hard. But I think it's kind
of one of the only obvious solutions that's
going to be out there as Japan society gets
more grey hair over the years.
SIERRA: So what about automation?
COOPER: Absolutely. Automation is one excellent
opportunity we've already seen Japan had this
way. And you can see that interest in automation
in, for example, the military, where Japan
has been investing in ways to decrease, for
example, the number of people that are on
Japanese Self Defense Force ships, by increasing
robotics and automation. So effectively, it
is investing more capital to decrease the
amount of labor that it needs in these areas.
And that's just a smart response, right from
an economy that has more capital than it does
labor. So I think automation will make a lot
of sense in Japan. But some of the challenges
are that automation won't solve all these
problems, right, eldercare, for example, which
we were just talking about. That's something
that's pretty hard to just automate. And so
Japan is going to have to look to a mix of
solutions. But I would expect that automation
will absolutely be one of the primary means
by which Japan tries to manage this difficult
time.
SIERRA: There s no doubt that Japan faces
a serious challenge curbing its decline. The
cultural and social changes required to do
so are daunting. But nobody should count them
out. Japan has demonstrated its capacity to
innovate and overcome challenges many times
in the past. There s every reason to root
for them.
SMITH: I think the danger for us here in the
United States is that we forget about Japan,
we're so focused on China and its rising power.
And that Chinese power often overshadows Japan,
our long term ally and dynamic economy in
its own right, but also a functioning and
strong democracy. This is a friendship we
shouldn't take for granted. This is a friendship
we shouldn't take for granted. And I think
it's important that Americans understand the
strength and the depth of the Japanese partnership
with the United States.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. Have a
question or some feedback? Just feel like
saying hi? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we d love it if you
could leave us a review. Ideally a good one,
the more stars the better. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our assistant podcast producer. Sophie
Yass is our summer intern. Robert McMahon
is our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey is
our Chief Digital Officer. Extra help for
this episode was provided by Lindsay Maizland
and Kali Robinson. Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why It Matters
this is Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See
you soon!